字幕: 大夢 髙橋
校正: Yoshiaki Yamagami
はじめまして
最近 合同会社「廃屋」という会社をつくった
西村周治といいます
よろしくお願いします
こんな写真のような 本当にボロボロの
緑に包まれて 中入れないぐらいになった
空き家を直して住んでます
これは僕が今 住んでいる家の
改装前の写真なんですけれども
こんな家 たまに町中でも
見かけたりするかもしれないんですが
こういう家を頑張って直して住んでいると
これ１戸だけじゃなくて
直して 住んで 出来たら引っ越して
直して住んでっていうのを
なんかずっと繰り返しているですね
固定した家を持たない
ヤドカリみたいな生活をしてます
これも本当に
ボロボロの家やったんですけど
家の原形を留めていないような家をですね
１年半ぐらい直して
ちょっといい感じになったと
何でこういう活動をし始めたかっていう
一番最初のきっかけなんですけれども
中学校の頃にですね 親がある時に
ボロボロの家を買ってきました
親は大工のテクニックとか
ノウハウ全くないんですけど
ないにも関わらずですね
お前ちょっとこれ直せっていうことを言われて
そこで英才教育を受けたんですね
床をつくったり ペンキを塗ったり
そういうことをしながらですね
何とか住めるようになったよみたいな感じで
そこで凄い成功体験がありました
その後ですね 高校生になってですね
ここで学校もあまり行かんとですね
ちょっと夜中にバイク運転してたらですね
大事故を起こしてしまうんですね
なんか生きるか死ぬかみたいな
あの世とこの世を反復横跳びするみたいな
そんな状況でですね
なんとかこっち側に
腕のいいお医者さんのお陰で
こっち側に戻ってこれたんですけど
どうせ生きることができたから
自分のやりたいことだけやっていきたいなと
とりあえずやったことないことを
色々やってみたいなって
そういう思いになりました
で そんなわがままな感じなんでですね
社会人になって一応就職試験を
受けたんですけども全部落ちまして
雇ってくれる会社は１つもなかったんですね
取りあえずアルバイトで
生計を成り立たせてたんですけれども
アルバイトもあんまりお金を稼ぐ事を
僕はあんまりやってなかったんで
当時月７万ぐらいしか貰ってなかったんですね
で その７万円でですね
家賃が ワンルームマンション
５万円のとこに住んでたんで
当然払えないと
払えなくなってですね
ある日もう来月で出ていってくださいって
来月からホームレスになる
という状況になりました
どうしたらええんねんと
めちゃ困ってですね 取りあえず
大学の先輩がそういう空き家改修とか
まちづくりみたいな活動をしていたので
その先輩に泣きついて
もうどんな家でもいいから
もうとにかく安い家紹介してくれって
屋根があったらそれでいい
屋根なくても
最悪作るからいいみたいな流れで
廃屋を借りました
屋根はあったんです
良かったことに
ただ床がなかったり
壁がなかったりしてたんですが
そういうので作っていたと
水道もつながってないのでつないで
電気は免許がいるんで
近所のおじさんに
お酒をおごって つないでもらって
何とか住めるようになりました
ただ 住めるようになったと言ってもですね
これお風呂は作ったんじゃない
これは拾ってきたお風呂なんですけど
拾ってきてたやつをですね 家に持ち帰って
これは壁にしようと これは風呂にしようと
そういう廃材を組み合わせて
生きるためにですね 家を直していったと
それが凄い そんとき
めちゃくちゃ楽しかったんですけれども
当時１万５千円の家賃で借りてたんですが
１万５千円も高いと ７万しか稼いでないから
ということで
３人でシェアすることになります
金ないやつが周りに
いっぱいいたんですね
３人でシェアすることで
１人５千円で住むことができました
７万円の７パーセントが５千円なんです
周りを見渡して見るとですね
一人暮らししてる人
めちゃくちゃ家賃結構高く払っていて
結構頑張って働いてるのに
お金がないみたいな人が多かったですね
これはちょっと不思議だなっていうのが
生きているだけでお金がかかるっていうのが
不思議だなとすごい思いました
その廃屋に住めるようになって
色んな人が来てくれようになりました
ある人はですね
はじめましてって会った瞬間にですね
僕 家 困ってるんです と言って
前の僕と一緒やんってなって
次の日からもう一緒に住んでるみたいな
そういう状況になっていました
色々な人が住んで
家に鍵が付いてなかったんで
窓も壊れているから
開け放しみたいな状況でですね
猫は入ってくるわ
近所のおじさんが酔っ払ったら入ってくるわ
トイレない家が多かったので 周りに
トイレ借りに来る人がいっぱいいるとか
そういう自由な誰が住人かわからへんみたいな
そういうカオスな状況が生まれていました
それのきっかけはですね
その先輩が紹介してくれてですね
そのエリア全体に
そういう人たちがいっぱい住み始めた
そういう活動があったことが
きっかけだったんですけれども
その辺り一帯の廃屋が
どんどん生まれ変わるような動きが起きました
みんなで町をハックしてですね
住むようなイメージで
そん時はすごい楽しかったです
近所も本当に下町だったので
色んな人が住んでます
生活保護を受けたりとか
受けて 毎日釣りに行く人とか
毎日昼間からお酒を飲む人とか
何かみんな働いているのか
働いていないのか分からないみたいな
そんな人ばかりが周りに
僕もしっかりその中の一員なんですけど
僕達の住んでいた町はボロボロだけど
あの人は稼いでないからとか
あの人は家族がいないからとか
そういう何か
後ろ指さされるようなことのないですね
すごく自由で寛容な町が
そこにあったんですね
ただその町もですね
ある時 きらきらした地上げ屋さんが
やってきてですね
この辺りもマンション建てるんで
全員出ていってくれみたいなこと言われました
僕らの家がどんどんなくなって
出て行かざるを得なくなったんですけれども
その後にですね こういう
ワンルームマンションが建っていきました
こういう建物はわりと投資家がですね
お金を儲けるために高く建てて
細かく部屋を区切って
それで収益を最大化させるような
仕組みの建物でした
土地は元々その時ですね
誰かから
大家さんから借りて住んでましたけど
結局あまり借りて
ずっと自由にしてたことがですね
そん時は当たり前のこととして
気付かなかったんですが
出て行けってなって出て行かされた時にですね
誰かが土地を占有していると
この地球のこの日本のこの神戸の一角は
誰かが土地を占有していて
その土地を占有している人によってですね
資本主義の中でですね
町並みが変わっていくということを知りました
投資家がお金稼ぎを目的とした
町づくりがされていく状況を目の当たりにして
この資本主義の世の中でどういう風に
回ってるんだという現実を知ったんですけど
本当にそこに
愛はあるんだろうかなとすごく思いました
愛のある町づくりというか
愛のある町どんなやろって
まあ元々いたとこがそういうものであったと
僕は思ったんですけれども
なぜそういうとこが生まれるんだろうかな
というのを凄い思いました
でちょうどその頃ですね
強制退去になった頃ですね
母親が亡くなりました
ちょっと闘病してて
自ら死を選んだという形なんですけど
そん時に僕がですね
また生きる意味というのを
凄い考えさせられました
どう生きていったらいいんだろうとか
どう生きていったら凄い生きてる感覚が
あるんだろうみたいなことを考えた時に
廃屋を直してる時が一番
まぁ直して人に使ってもらって 遊んで愛して
使ってもらった時が一番楽しかったんですね
それをもう一回ちゃんと
やり始めようかなと思って
定職について家を直し始めます
こういう解体現場ってよく町中で
見かけると思うんですけど
こういう解体現場とかにですね
色んなまだまだ使える材料が眠ってました
で そういうのを引っ張り出して
昔みたいにまた作ってる家に
どんどんインストールして
直していくっていうことを始めました
で こういう古い建物だけじゃなくて
今新しい建物も解体される
という現実があります
分譲マンションを売る時にですね
モデルルームを建てて
そのモデルルームが分譲マンションが売れたら
大まか廃棄されるという状況なんですけれども
そういうところに行ってですね
ガラスとか断熱材とかそういうマテリアルを
レスキューして自分の現場に使うと
そういうこともやってます
ちょっと変わった直し方をしているのでですね
周りにメンバーもいっぱい増えてきました
海外から来た旅人とか
写真家とか絵描きとか
色んなアーティストとかが
現場に加わってくれるようになりました
コロナで仕事なくなった人とか
昔の僕みたいに
気が向いたときだけ働きたい人だとか
お金を介在させないで生活したい人とか
０円で生活したい人とか
そういう人がですね
現場に働きに来て 気が向いた時に働きに来て
みんなでいっぱいの家を直していく
そういう活動をやっています
である時 とある一軒の
ボロボロの家を直してたらですね
隣の人がうちの家買ってくれないか
という話になりました
その人はボロボロになった家を持ってるけど
自分が生まれ育った場所への愛着もあるけど
利活用することもできないと
なかなか困ってはったという状況なんですけど
僕が隣で一生懸命直してるものだから
そんな風に直してくれるんやったら
ぜひ譲りたいということですね
その方から家を譲ってもらうことになります
よく見渡すとこの周り
全部空き家やったんですね
実はね もうみんな空家 困っている
という状況だったんですよ
もう本当に順番にですね　いや もうこれ
どうにかしてくださいみたいな感じで
一戸一戸譲ってもらう
という形になっていきました
で この辺り一帯が気付けば
村みたいな規模になっていました
村みたいな規模になるとですね
建物と建物の間に高いブロック塀が
いっぱい建ってたんですけど
そういうのが全部いらなくなるんで
全て撤去していくとですね
薄暗い場所が明るくて広い場所に
どんどん変わっていきました
で その場所にですね 今畑をやったり
ニワトリを飼ったり色んなことしてます
誰も使わないような場所が
誰もが入れるような場所に
どんどん変わっていったと
今 これ村の全体の図面なんですけど
半分ぐらいはですね
みんなで共有できる場所として開放してます
そこで鶏を飼ったり 畑したり
キッチン作ったり ベンチを置いたりですね
誰もが入らない 占有する場所じゃなくて
誰でも入れる共有する場所として
それを増やしていってます
わざわざ何でこういうことを
するかと言うとですね
今 空き家がもう増えていって
いっぱい余っているという状況は
建物そのものの価値がなくなってきていると
で その建物の周りがですね
どういう風に使われているかで
その建物の周りをですね
その住む人だけじゃなくて
その地域の人がどういう風に
使っているかということで
その建物の価値が決まってくると
そういう風に考えています
共有地としているところもあったり
あと０円で住める家とか
そういうのも作ったりしています
この前何かイーロン・マスクがですね
日本は消滅するみたいなことを
言ってましたけど
日本はですね
少子高齢化でどんどん人口が減っていく
一方で さっきみたいな新しい建物は
どんどんどんどん建っていると
当然ながらそうなると空き家がいっぱい
右肩上がりに増えていく状況になります
このままでは日本は世界一の
空き家大国になるっていわれています
今でも空き家問題って結構ネガティブに
ニュースで取り上げられたりしてるんですけど
わりと僕はそんな風に思ってなくて
有効活用できる資産がですね
どんどんどんどん
未来に増えていくと思ってます
それをポジティブに捉えることで ちょっと
未来が大きく変わってくるような気がしてます
後ですね 空き家の資産価値の
格差もすごい大きくなってます
僕が最初見て頂いた写真の
僕が住んでる家はですね
平米3,800円で買ったんですけど
東京の一番高いところではですね
もう何か桁が分からない数字になっている
もう万倍以上の差がですね
同じ土と同じ空気で構成されてる場所に
価値の差が生まれている
これがもうめちゃくちゃ
気持ち悪いなと思って
所詮土地なんてもう
同じ土 同じ空気なんかで
構成されているはずなので
どんな場所でも豊かな場所に
変化するんじゃないかなと思っています
色々空き家問題について話してきましたけど
僕が結論として言いたいことはですね
この世界には両方があります
光があって 闇があります
生があって 死があります
新築が過剰に供給される一方で
廃屋がどんどん生まれてきてるという状況です
製品がいっぱい作られて余ってる状況で
一方で ゴミがどんどん廃棄されている
という状況があります
この両方にもですね これは
良い悪いじゃなくて意味があると思ってます
その意味があるから
両方存在してると思ってます
どちらか一方の場所にいるとですね
もう一方がどうしても
見えにくくなってしまうと思うんですけれども
その一方の世界にいると
なかなか見えないですね
対極の存在を知ってもらいたいし
意味を持たせたいなって思ってます
だからですね 価値がないと
本当に誰も見向きもしないような
廃屋とかごみとかそういうものを使ってですね
今のこういう活動をやっております
以上です
ありがとうございました